ja das ist gründlich schiefgegangen
pünktlich zum 50 jährigen jubiläum der
mondlandung wollte indien eine rakete
zum mond starten aber das ganze wurde
abgeblasen warum wieso weshalb was war
das problem
pixum science fiction gibst täglich
faszinierendes heinz videos abonniert
den kanal nur dann verpasst er nichts
herzlich willkommen drei jahren zwei die
rakete sollte gestern staaten aber dann
gab es probleme der stadt wurde
abgebrochen
es gibt ja bei solchen raketenstart
mehrere punkte wo gecheckt wird was ist
los und dann müssen alle controller ihr
go geben und der controller der für die
helium tanks zuständig war
der musste den start abbrechen wir
werden ja im live stream zum apollo
start am samstag um 21 uhr genau über
diesen fakt berichten wann wird der
startbahn wird überhaupt die missionen
an welchen punkten wieso weshalb warum
abgebrochen in diesem fall war es so
dass der helium tank auf 350 bar gesetzt
werden sollte also sollte soviel helium
eingefüllt werden bis ein druck von 350
bar erreicht werden sollte aber das
geschah nicht der druck ging immer
wieder zurück helium ist an bord der
schon 32 um wenn wasserstoff und
sauerstoff in den triebwerken verbrannt
wird die tanks langsam leer laufen
helium nach zu pumpen damit der druck in
den wasserstoff und sauerstoff tanks
immer gleich bleibt das waren sich
wichtig wenn der nämlich singt dann
kriegen die triebwerke nicht genug
treibstoff und sind nicht richtig und
dann ist der ganze flug nicht
kalkulierbar also dieser helium tank ist
von entscheidender bedeutung wenn das
nicht funktioniert dann kann so eine
mission schief gehen so also helium ist
nicht den druck nicht aufgebaut und also
es muss ein leck gegeben und jetzt wird
sogar vermutet dass es mehrere lecks
gibt mit dieser mission hätte sich
indien eingereiht in die bisherigen
nationen die auf dem mond gelandet sind
das waren natürlich die usa mit der
apollo mission
das waren die russen mit diverse
mond sonden und das war china das ganze
ist ein bisschen schade denn die inder
hätten eine sonder an einem ort
abgesetzt wurden nicht so viele sonnen
landen nämlich nicht in der nähe des
äquators sondern mehr in der nähe des
südpols 70 breitengrad war anvisiert
interessant ist es deshalb weil dort ja
in der nähe des südpols wird wasser
vermutet und das hätte man suchen können
und zwar mit einer lande sonde vikram
und zusätzlich besonders war noch dass
ein rover an bord der sonde war praxen
er konnte die sonde verlassen und im
umkreis von 500 metern den mond
untersuchen und vielleicht dort dann zum
ersten mal wasser finden wie es ja auf
dem mars schon geschehen ist am
kommenden samstag wird es jetzt spannend
da jetzt sich nämlich die apollo 11
landung auf dem mond zum fünfzigsten mal
und wir machen den live stream um 21 uhr
mit ganz vielen wissenschafts youtube an
einer von ihnen wird also comics tv sein
und er zählt hier die fünf wichtigsten
fakten über die mondlandung auf und hier
da geht es zum live stream also schaltet
ein am samstag um 21 uhr zwölf stunden
lang bis zum nächsten morgen 9 uhr
begleiten wir quasi live die mondlandung
vor 50 jahren bis dann bleibt dran